who is a full professor at the technical
university of graz in austria
uh roderick roderick has uh worked on
many
aspects of formal methods verification
synthesis
and particularly reactive synthesis and
in recent years he has been taking
reactive synthesis in a very interesting
and novel direction
which is uh this exciting topic of
shield synthesis
and so i'm really excited to have rodrik
speak about that here today
welcome okay great thank you very much
uh thanks for the invitation it's a
great honor to speak of the
simon's institute even though i'm at
home
i have it still um so i'll talk about
shield synthesis as
sanjit said so this is
work with a whole bunch of people uh but
i especially want to
uh mention bettina kunikova
so she was my phd student she finished
last year she's staying on for a little
bit more and she's driven most of this
and you know done most of the
collaborations and come up with most of
the ideas
so it's really it's really her work all
right
so um the uh the idea is
uh you um you know how to do synthesis
uh but you also know what's not perfect
and you want uh to be able to do a
little bit
more with that so to kick off the
motivation i have this
slide here that uh you will probably
know
um so this is um it comes from a
newspaper article
and it says a software bundle to the
death in the uber self-driving crash
and then it says sensors detected elaine
herzberg but software reportedly
decided to ignore her now
i don't know if this is true right uh
this is a newspaper article and then you
probably should take this with a grain
of salt but but let's take it as
uh at face value right so if um
if the car actually knew that
the pedestrian was there and then
the software decided that this is not a
big deal
that's a really bad thing right if um
so from my perspective there's a formal
methods person i i could understand
if the software fails to understand
that you know the picture it's seeing uh
represents pedestrians
it seems to be a complicated thing but
sort of
linking the the
the fact that you've detected the person
to the fact that you should stop
this should be really simple right uh
it's almost trivial to write down this
rule
role
you you sit down with the class of
school kids and you ask them what should
a
self-driving car do one of the first
things they will tell you is and not
run into pedestrians um so so again
i i'm not sure if if this is really
inside of the of the problem is this the
root cause
i don't know um but there's nothing
inside of this machine learned system
that
guarantees that this rule
is is maintained it's nothing that
guarantees that if you see a pedestrian
the car will stop um
and and this should to my mind obviously
be in there um so let's see if we
can sort of do something like that right
so can
you combine uh the smarts that a
self-driving car has
with the guarantees that formal
methods have um so i don't believe
that you can use formal methods or
synthesis to just
build a self-driving car uh there's too
much optimization and
tuning and smartness in there but but to
to enforce simple rules that we should
be able to do
okay so let's take a step back and see
what this problem
looks like um so if you uh
a formal methods person i think all of
you are
then verification or synthesis
looks like this right there's a system m
and there's a formula phi and all you
need to do is make sure that there's a
double turn style in between and
everything is fine
um so why is this difficult this is
difficult because the system is a pain
and also the specifications of pain
right
so your system is large uh
consists of different aspects analog
components discrete components
machine learned things hard coded things
where you don't have the source code
i don't know there might be soft errors
in it there's all kinds of
difficulties in representing the system
and your specification if you think of
it um
it's not so easy either if you want to
write down exactly what a
self-driving car should do this becomes
a
really difficult thing you have to deal
with
the smoothness of the steering and the
smoothness of the braking and
you know how precisely this works and
these are things
you know where we've made a lot of
progress but we're not
perfect at specifying things like that
and
it might be easier to to implement these
or to learn them
um so um so so this seems to
be like an impossible problem um and
then i think sort of as far as
as far as the system is concerned i
don't see a lot of hope right
you can try and dice it up into little
pieces and
there's lots of tricks you can play but
the enter system is complicated
the spec spec i'm not so sure
so i think you don't need such a
complicated spec i think
if you're going to talk about the things
that uh that really matter there the
specification is small and it's sweet
um so this is
maybe true may not be true but this is
the the um
the underlying assumption for the talk
uh
we can come up with a set of
specifications
that sort of preclude uh the disastrous
uh that really look at the critical
aspects of your system
and these should be simple to specify
uh and they should be small and i'm also
sort of assuming that
that this is uh expressible at all right
so something like
if you see the pedestrian stop the car
this is something you can state
something like uh you know if you
uh if your camera sees a tree it should
actually report tree
i have no idea how to deal with that so
that's sort of outside of the scope
before we'll talk about today
all right so so let's um take this
assumption
let's say we have a complicated system
we have a simple spec
and then the next thing you'll try to do
is you'll try to verify it
and it's not clear that this will
succeed
right um if the system is complicated
enough then testing is not going to cut
it
model checking or any kinds of formal
methods
may just fail so this
this here's another assumption system so
complicated you cannot just
verify it so what do you do
this is sort of the whole talk here in
one slide what do you do instead
you build a shield you build a runtime
enforcement module for a reactive system
that looks at the outputs of the system
i may also look at the inputs and uh
normally
it will say everything's fine but every
now and then
if something disastrous is about to
happen the shield may come and say no no
i don't like
that out you're leaving the winning
region
don't do that i will give you a
different
output um
now the hope here of course is sort of
all of the smartness that the designer
or
the machine learning algorithm has put
into the system
this gets preserved you know as long as
nothing bad happens
you don't see the shield it's completely
transparent
but if something bad happens it it
interferes so you get the best of both
worlds right
you get a brilliant machine learning
system with guarantees
now if i claim
that verification is impossible then
synthesis should be even harder
and here the hope is that but that is
not true and the critical spec
remembers is supposed to be really small
so you should be able to synthesize a
shield out of it
now how exactly the synthesis works i'll
spend a few more words on that
but basically you know if you can write
down a specification of what the shield
should do
you can build it automatically
um so is this a completely new idea
no it's not right if you have
your own traffic light controller system
in your back
backyard you can buy things like this
right so
you can google for this thing it's
called the traffic tech cmu conflict
monitor unit
and you hook this up to your traffic
light system and uh
you look in the manual it says when two
channels so that's two
traffic lights that sort of intersect if
two channels are in conflict
uh this box here will activate a
conflict signal
the signal is read by the traffic
controller which will then place the
intersection in flash
right so that means it's nice you've
programmed your um
your traffic light and you've made a
mistake so the thing runs
correctly for a long time but at some
point something goes wrong a
bug turns up and this little box will
notice
and your intersection will go into
flashing
i don't know yellow or flashing red one
of the two
uh and people will start paying
attention and everything will be fine
um so this is kind of what we what we
want
what we like here is that this box
you don't have to tell it what your
traffic light controller is like
it's not going to look inside of it it
treats it as a black box
so that we want to keep but i'm not so
happy
with this thing for two reasons so the
first thing
is i don't want to hard code it for
you know intersections i want
it to be able to deal with sort of
general specifications
and i want to automatically build this
box from spec
and the other thing i'm not so happy
with here is sort of if something goes
wrong then we do the dumbest possible
thing
right we we go to field safe mode and
and
you know maybe we'll send a text message
to uh to somebody who
will come and reset the intersection and
then start
from scratch you want something smarter
in some way okay so let's try and
formalize that a little bit
um so what do we want and i have a
picture of our
system here so i have a system and a
shield again
and the first thing i want and i hope
that this is obvious is that
between the input to the system and the
output of the shielded system
this pair should fulfill the
specification right the shield the
system should be correct
um so you'd think this is enough
that you'd be wrong um if you only
require this then you can just do
synthesis
on your spec and your shield will just
look at the inputs
and produce new outputs and it doesn't
have to look at the system i
can just remove this uh arrow over here
um so what's missing in my
my presentation here is the fact that
the shield should sort of
normally just do what the system
proposes um
so um so we want minimum interference
and i'll split that into two properties
the first thing that i
want is that um okay so two words
i will use the word violation to uh to
mean that the system does something
wrong
it goes into an action so that i cannot
guarantee
that in the future it will always stick
to the spec
that does something wrong and deviation
i will say if the shield
changes the output of the system i will
call that a deviation
so the first thing is don't touch the
outputs of the system
unless you absolutely have to right
deviate only if necessary
and this means that as long as the run
of the system
doesn't have a failure you will not
see you will not notice the shield
and then the second thing and this is a
little bit bigger and
less clear um i sort of want to have as
little deviation as possible
um i want i don't want the intersection
to go into
flashing yellow mode i if there's two
traffic lights that cannot both be green
at the same time well then
change one to red but don't just
completely reset the system
right and the idea is here that even if
you have a failure
um the shield will sort of enforce these
critical properties
but there's a whole bunch of other
properties that the system has
and you want to retain as many of these
as you can
you cannot kind of really guarantee that
because you don't know what
the non-critical properties are but you
want or no prime to be as close as
possible
um how do you do that so so let me give
you one
idea on how to do that and then you can
think of
more ideas of your own
so if this here is the arrow of time um
so initially everything is fine the
system's just
going along doing everything it's
supposed to do so the shield cannot
touch the output
and then the specification might be
violated by the system uh this means
that from now on the shield can
change the output a little bit and sort
of the simplest thing you could think of
here
is to have a bound and to say
that the shield can change the outputs
for k steps
when the k steps are over the deviation
changing the output is forbidden again
and if then another error comes then you
can
change the outputs for k steps again
um there's a few difficulties in this um
definition right so you have to figure
out what it means
to have two violations of the uh of the
specifications this is not
very well defined um
but you can think of a way to deal with
that and
and and then there's sort of a
simplistic idea i'm sure you can think
of something better
right as soon as you have whatever a
steering wheel with a tilt
um you know uh turning the steering
wheel
90 degrees the other direction is
probably a bigger deviation
than just turning it by one degree
right so it depends on your application
domain here
okay um so then
you want to do you want to build
this shield and i have to look at my
time
uh what can you do you use games
um so i'm going to try and skip the
formalization here because uh
will take too much time um but you have
we have these
three requirements right you say the
shield has to be correct
so the input output relation has to fit
with with
the spec it can deviate only if
necessary
this is not so hard to formalize right
you know what the spec
is so you can play a game on this and
you know when
a an action that is proposed is not a
winning
um not a winning move in your game
so this is the moment when the shield
can interfere
um and you want the shield to deviate as
little as possible
so the simple solution here is you keep
track of when
there's a difference between what the
shield says and what the system says
and then the shield has to as quickly as
possible go back into a mode where it
just copies
the system output into the shield output
you can
specify this as a your key game
the important thing here is is sort of
you don't on this slide i'm not trying
to implement
the shield i'm trying to say what are
the properties that the shield should
have
and as soon as i have these properties
you guys all know about synthesis
you give this to your favorite synthesis
tool
it'll give you a shield and i have an
example but i'll just uh
uh skip it um
yeah so you have let me just show you
sort of abstractly the slide right so
you have a normal mode
in which whatever the traffic light
controller in this case does is just
copied by the shield
you have things that the shield is just
not allowed to do
and you have a recovery mode in which
the shield has changed the output of the
system
and then it's quickly as possible to go
back to the normal mode
okay so let's skip that
and give you more interesting examples
right
um so so this is uh
sort of the the main idea
uh right so you have the system maybe as
complicated as possible
you want to change the outputs only if
necessary and as little as possible um
there's all bunch of stuff around this
right so if
shield may not exist uh with the
question the answer to your synthesis
question may
be no this is not realizable you cannot
always guarantee
say a finite recovery time then you have
to do something else
you could think of collaborative
strategies for instance
um but let me show you um some examples
here
in the next five minutes or so
so machine learning let me skip the
philosophy here
and go straight to an example so
um we have the same picture here that uh
that i had before
right now instead of what i call a
system we have a learning agent
uh here we've made the environment
explicit so there's observations
there's rewards and i have a shield that
sits
after the learning agent in this case
let me change the actions of the
learning agents
now there's a couple of different
decisions you could take here on how to
train
the learning agent so the important
important thing i think is that
the shield is in place during learning
so you know that nothing horrible
happens while the agent learns
the shield of course is still there when
the
agent is done learning when you are in
the field and the system's just running
because this learning agent no matter
what you do with it
doesn't give you any guarantees right
now there's different choices on what
you do with the rewards
the learning agent does something bad
something that you correct do you
slap it on the wrist or do you say well
it doesn't matter because the shield
corrects the action anyway and these are
sort of parameters you can play with and
you can
see what works best um
in practice we you know we give a
negative feedback
this sort of seems to generalize
um so here you see um in
an example this is sort of our
prototypical example of shielding
pac-man and so on the left this is a
standard machine learning thing
it's learning how to eat the dots and if
if beckman gets eaten that's a high
negative reward
on the right the machine learning system
still trying to eat the dots
um i know how to formalize that but it
becomes very complicated
the shield makes sure that pac-man
doesn't get eaten
beckman wants to go in the wrong
direction wants to go into a dead end
then the shield will interfere and you
see that i think you saw it over here
at some point where yeah where it keeps
going around and
waits for for the ghost to go away so
that it can
ease the last dots so this is nice on
the right i have guarantees specman will
never get eaten
[Music]
and still machine learning is very good
what you see as well if you look at this
is that
we can learn these things more quickly
um you see the rewards here without a
shield in an orange with a shield
so rewards go up quickly and stay high
from there um there's no guarantee so so
i can guarantee
that your learning algorithm will still
converge even if you have a shield
i cannot guarantee that it's faster and
i have
examples where this is not the case
um but there's a lot there's a bunch of
examples where it is the case
okay um so then what what you're
thinking here
is uh well that's nice but uh when i
last played pacman
there were four ghosts and the
grid was a lot bigger so that's what you
really want to do
right so you formalize
this this thing with the four ghosts uh
the ghosts here are obviously modeled as
adversarial right you don't know where
they're going
you want to be safe and then obviously
or
obviously to me by now the tool says i
cannot build a shield for
that that was not realizable why not
uh because if you have four ghosts it's
very
simple for them to corner pac-man
one corner of the uh of the field and
eden
um so you're going to lose um so what do
you do so this is realistic right
if you're um sort of driving your
autonomous car on the highway you want
to make sure that you're safe
this is not going to work the only way
to have
100 guarantees on autonomous driving is
if you leave your car and
in the driveway um
so what you could do here is um is you
could learn
what these sorry what these ghosts do
uh as a probabilistic model so you can
model each of the ghosts as a markov
chain
[Music]
and then how to control pacman becomes a
markov decision
process so it's a it's a game with
a probabilistic aspect versus one player
which is you and half a player which is
chance and then you can say
well i want a property like i'm not the
pac-man
is not going to be eaten in with a
probability larger than 5
within the next 10 steps
so i no longer have hard guarantees here
and now my
guarantees become probabilistic
so let's look at that i have that as
well
[Music]
let's see
yes there we go so this is slower so on
the left you again you see
the original pac-man no shield and
you'll get eaten
on the right you'll see pacman with the
shield
he also gets eaten occasionally
but not nearly as much and what you see
are these traffic lights
so when pac-man comes to an intersection
he poses a question to the shield and he
says are the chances of getting eaten
for these directions acceptable or not
and
sort of you always want to have at least
one green light and this is a safe
direction that you can go in
and as you'll see there are sometimes
sometimes there are no good choices yeah
things may go wrong
um okay um
and i think i'm running out of time um
so there's lots of things you can do
here right so
i've presented this as sort of something
where you can guarantee
safety constraints but look at this as
something to you know increase
performance of a learning system
whereby making local decisions more
smartly using a formal model
you can react very well to situations
where you didn't train for them
you can extend this to time systems
and you can extend this to multi-agent
systems
uh but also you can say
we've been going on for 25 minutes and
we should go
for a coffee break so i'm not going to
talk about all of this
um i i think they're all sort of
relatively straightforward well
extensions of the basic idea
maybe that's a bit uh uh exaggerated
uh but the basic idea is the main thing
that
you should understand okay so
let's see i should be able to click here
no all right
then i will skip to the end
good yeah so um
i talked about shields right so the idea
is
you know you have a system the system is
almost perfect and maybe it is even
perfect but i have no guarantees and
they want to add guarantees onto the
system
uh there's a bunch of uh assumptions
right so uh
the system acts as a reactive system um
it's something where i can write down
specifications and i can actually
verify whether the specification has
been fulfilled or not so we're not
talking about any of this fuzzy stuff
like in
image recognition
and then we build a runtime enforcement
module that can guarantee correct
correctness
and doesn't change the output too much
uh if it doesn't have to
um and then there's a whole bunch of
other things
you can do right so um we've only talked
about boolean systems what about
non-boolean systems
uh what about distributed shields uh
what about partial observability
um i don't know the answers to all of
this
uh but i'm sure there there's many more
ideas that
we could follow okay so that's it from
my side
thank you very much for your attention
thank you roderick
um i don't see any questions in the chat
or q a
but i have a question um
so for shield synthesis what information
do we need about the system
or about the environment in order to
synthesize the shield
can you clarify that for us
so we treat both the system
and the environment in the basic setting
as adversarial
now you can change your mind and you
could see either the environment or
the system as a probabilistic entity
and sort of the simplest answer i think
is then that you need
no information about the environment or
about the system
um and then you get back to sort of the
standard question of when you verify
something right can you just assume that
the system that the environment can do
anything
um so you may need assumptions on the
environment
um i don't know if that answers your
question so the the other aspect of this
maybe is that
we have this assumption that you know we
can represent everything in a
state-based system
that there's enough observability
and that there's actually i can always
make a statement of
this is correct this is not this is not
correct
so i'm just wondering because it seems
like if you had no information
it's back to the full reactive synthesis
setting right effectively if you're
assuming that
these are adversarial and then also if
you
if you don't use any information about
the system how do you guarantee this
minimum deviation property
um so you um
okay so
so you look at the at the system as
let's say a refinement of
the let's say you start with a safety
specification right
and then your system is a refinement of
your uh of your safety specification
yeah i'm finding a little bit but that's
close enough
um so so um you always know
where the system is inside of your
safety spec
you can follow this um
until something goes wrong and and then
you have to sort of start making
assumptions
and and our basic assumption is that if
the system does something wrong
um it's still it's going to be knocked
off it'll be in a different state maybe
but
it will still be in some state
uh inside of the safety specification
and so yeah so you have to figure out
where it is and then to start following
it again
um so this is in a way the uh
the worst case assumption right if you
have a byzantine system
then you have no chance that you'll go
back to sort of synchronizing with it um
if it's um yeah but if it's not
byzantine if it's just
uh like a glitch uh then you have to
figure out
what the state is that it's in and you
can do that by just observing its
outputs
and again when i talk about the state
that the system is in i'm talking about
the
safety automaton for the specification
of which the system is refined all right
that makes sense
yeah thank you roderick uh there's
another question on
q a but i think we'll have to move on to
the next talk
but i hope you can answer that frederick
um
okay our next speaker is uh is professor
nir peterman